there are some very strong reasons why
Partners breaking up generally try to
remain friends
to the person being however nicely
rejected the promise of friendship can
feel like an emotionally reassuring
consolation prize
we may no longer be able to share their
bed have children with them or end our
days in their company but at least
something can be rescued From the Ashes
we will continue to be able to call them
when we like share our fears and go to
the movies together to the person
performing however nicely the execution
the promise of friendship is equally
attractive we may be itching to eject
the partner but we are not for that
matter devoid a feeling we are as we
might say in sentimental moments
extremely fond of the soon-to-be-x we
just don't want to end our time on Earth
with them let alone reject all sexual
possibilities in their name furthermore
we're deeply attached to the idea that
we're not monsters and as we know nice
people always try to be friends with
their exes
the arguments may sound wise but from
close up they are deeply fraught and in
their own way a catastrophe for both
sides
for the rejected party the step from
lover to friend is an eternally
humiliating demotion to go from the idea
of a joint lifelong future to a dinner
every second Thursday is to put it
mildly a come down
worse every sighting of the x is
guaranteed to reignite Hope and then
further insult what isn't acquiring a
friend more an unwitting torturer
as for the executing party the x is a
constant reminder of guilt and
ruthlessness one can't even ever be too
kind lest one's intentions be misread
and after a few drinks they burst into
tears or attempt to make a move
the idea of trying to be friends
constitutes a touching attempt to honor
the best sides of a relationship in
which two people invested heavily lovers
can't so the thought goes simply vanish
from each other's lives after all that
friendship is invoked to memorialize an
episode of genuine importance
but looked at more dispassionately
friendship isn't in any real sense
faithful to love
friendship with an ex does a grave
disservice both to the memory of the
relationship at its height and the
merits of intimate friendship it's at
once a betrayal of everything a good
relationship was and a slight on the
ideals of friendship which shouldn't be
built out of the remnants of another
more Ardent condition
what we should replace love with isn't
friendship but that far more honest
state
civil distance that and a real assurance
that their relationship in its best and
most enduring light will always live on
in the one place it can safely always do
so
memory
[Music]